you know those people you see on guided
Segway tours you know how you laugh at
those people and swear you'd never do
that
well segway may have finally solved its
uncool problem kind of this is the
Segway mini pro and it's essentially a
Segway without that huge cumbersome
handle it's also kind of an evolution of
hoverboard you know those super fun but
horribly unsafe two-wheeled scooters
that took over the world and then burnt
down a few homes while doing
Segway actually worked with regulators
to set up tests and standards for
hoverboards and the Mini Pro is one of
the first certified devices it's a
pretty serious team it goes up to ten
miles an hour and 14 miles on a chart it
has actual air filled tires which makes
it much easier to go over rougher
terrain Jesus don't run over holes
that's rule number one kids the whole
things about two feet wide by two and a
half feet tall and because it's so
sturdy it was a huge 28 pounds it has
headlights and taillights which you can
customize in the companion app on bump
you can do a lot in the app actually
even drive the thing around nobody on it
that comes in handy more than you think
you can undo dizzy by just spinning okay
didn't look like the hoverboard you lean
forward and backward to move but you
mostly sear with your knees pushing
against this control board it gives you
super tight turns and really good
control it feels weird it's like you're
skiing except you don't have skis or
look cool that's because after all this
is still a Segway and at $1,000 it's
also horribly the cheapest way to get
from point A to point B but this is just
the first in a new breed of device
that's safe and fun and usable all at
the same time so maybe next time Segway
will also make something cool some
well